thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story
doomed to fail President Putin tries to
face down what he calls a rebellion
insisting his country is United behind
him
if the organizers of this Rebellion
is
cannot but understand that they will be
brought to Justice
The Man Behind it says he wasn't trying
to force out President Putin and that
some Russians are disappointed that he
stopped
we were going for a demonstration of our
protest
not to overthrow the government in the
country
[Music]
despite the Rebellion there's no new
foothold on the front line for Ukraine
Soldiers the report from Moscow and Kiev
tonight
fairly clear at the point of entry
on both sides there's nothing that could
have stopped her
also on the program how Nicola bully had
drowned before anyone even realized she
was missing the evidence heard at her
inquest today
following in the footsteps of his mother
Prince William pledges what is called
his life's ambition to end homelessness
it's not match point yet Andy Murray
tells guy news he hopes this won't be
his last Wimbledon you know I know it's
not going to be going on forever but I
have an idea of when I would you know I
would like to finish and it's not this
year's Wimbledon
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
foreign
Putin said tonight that the organizers
of what he called the weekend's
Rebellion would be brought to Justice
and that any black male would be doomed
to failure he was speaking after the man
behind that Rebellion the mercenary
Bossier Afghani pregosian denied he'd
planned to overthrow the government but
said many people were still supporting
him President Biden echoed other Western
leaders when he said that NATO had had
no role in what he called a struggle
inside the Russian system tonight we'll
see what impact the turmoil has had on
the Ukrainian Battlefield and speak to
our correspondent in Kiev but first from
Moscow Tana magnet reports
a late night statement from Vladimir
Putin thanking the nation for standing
United he said in the face of those who
had brought it to the brink
the organizers understood that this was
a criminal undertaking which would split
the country and weaken us which is
facing a colossal external threat
the organizers of this event were
sending their troops to their death
Under Fire and to shoot their own people
this is precisely the suicidal outcome
the enemies of Russia the neo-naz is in
Kiev and their Western mind is wanted
few hours earlier The Man Behind the
gravest crisis in the president's
23-year rule Wagner boss yevgeni
bregozian had broken his silence with a
long audio message explaining why he'd
stopped the march to Moscow
is
earlier on Monday this video of Defense
Minister Sergey shoigu the focus of
pregosian's Roth was released touring
his units no way of verifying when that
was filmed but the purpose was clear to
show him back at work and unruffled as
questions swirl over his future
you'll often hear Russians especially
during tumultuous times quote the old
proverb don't swap horses Midstream and
Vladimir Putin will want to resist
looking like he's caving into pressure
especially from a man he's branded
treasonous by reshuffling his top
military command right in the middle of
his war in Ukraine
foreign
was branded a traitor and a rebel his
march on Moscow called crazy and
senseless but pregotian said he'd had
plenty of support from the Russian
public
foreign
[Music]
was hardly the type to go quietly and it
will appear now as though Putin is
determined to extinguish his voice for
good Dynamic day Sky News Moscow
President Putin in his statement tonight
also claimed that Ukraine was involved
in the weekend Rebellion but on the
battlefield the signs are that the
turmoil in Russia has not led to any
major breakthrough here the foreign
secretary said that the challenge to the
Russian leaders Authority was yet more
evidence that his forces should withdraw
our security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes has this report
mm-hmm
Ukrainian soldiers risked their lives to
save another
under Russian fire
they reach the casualty then a scramble
to evacuate the drama in Russia hasn't
stopped the devastation in Ukraine but
the uprising by a mercenary boss is
being seen as a sign of weakness for
Vladimir Putin
the United States and its allies were
Keen to tell Moscow they had nothing to
do with the crisis
no excuse to blame this on the west or
to blame us on NATO
we made clear that we were not involved
the ultimate outcome of all this remains
to be seen But no matter what comes next
I will keep making sure that our allies
and our partners are closely aligned in
the UK the foreign secretary chose to
highlight how the Wagner boss yevgeny
pagosan publicly rubbished Putin's
justification for the war in Ukraine in
an act of defiance regossians Rebellion
is an unprecedented challenge to
President Putin's Authority and it is
clear that cracks are emerging in the
Russian support for the war now that
Russia's leadership cannot justify this
war even to each other the only rightful
course is for Putin to withdraw his
troops and end this Bloodshed now Moscow
had its own message for London it
claimed these images were of a British
spy plane that Russian aircraft had
scrambled to intercept as well as two
British fighter jets near Russian air
face over the Black Sea it all comes as
a Ukrainian counter-offensive rages on
with Ukraine saying its forces have
retaken more than 80 square miles of
territory it's perhaps slower progress
than some had expected on front lines to
the South around zaparisia and in the
East near bakmut
but the Russians have dug deep defensive
lines shown here in red and moving
forward is perilous work
this is what it looks like on the ground
the Ukrainian troops need to find a weak
spot here
not just in Putin's regime
debraham Sky News
well our International Affairs editor
Dominic where corn is in Kiev tonight
and Diana magnet is as we've seen in
Moscow Dominic no immediate Advance then
for Ukrainian forces but what does the
government there make of the Rebellion
inside their enemies borders
well I think they're definitely looking
on and I they aren't enjoying the the
chaos that's unfolding uh in in Russia
one of zelenski's key advisors tonight
said that the speech tonight gave his
verdict saying it was a truly Epoch
making address that determines the
future of Russia sarcastically more uh
the way the Kremlin build the speech
going to say the doubts have finally
dispelled Russia is waiting for a new
president so they're not really
concealing their Glee at what's going on
but I think in terms of the military
impact it depends on the answer to a few
questions first of all what happens to
the Wagner Fighters are they going to be
absorbed into the Russian military which
it would effectively emasculate the most
effective fighting force the Russians
have had during this war what happens to
the defense minister and chief of staff
shoigu and garasimov widely regarded as
pretty incompetent are they going to be
replaced as pregogian wanted to happen
as part of a deal done with him and
could they be replaced with more
formidable enemies for Ukraine I think
the other question is what happens to
the morale of the Russian soldiers who
have heard over the weekend the most
credible Commander pregogin described
the war being as being fought because of
lies and that being led by mentally ill
scumbags in his words but I think you
have to also accept that their morale
probably wasn't that good already I
think the bottom line for the ukrainians
is what they're trying to achieve in
their counter-offensive is an extremely
difficult military operation a combined
arms breaching operation has not really
been achieved by one Army against
another Army of comparable ability since
the second world war so whatever happens
I think in Russia won't be enough to
change that equation it certainly could
change what happens if they win in terms
of the impact to Russia any Ukrainian
Victory but certainly not in terms of
how the battle is fought and I think
that's why the ukrainians say to the
West ignore what's going on in Russia
don't be too distracted keep on
supporting us so that we can win
well to Moscow and Diana one of the more
consequential weekends of the war for
Russia at least President Putin
addressing it directly tonight so what
now
well I think what he was trying to do
tonight was to tell the Russian people
that the situation was uh the threat had
been faced off and the situation was as
under control as it possibly could be
whilst not alienating the thousands if
not tens of thousands of Wagner fighters
who um clearly had decided to back
pregogin in this short-lived Rebellion
um and make sure that they stayed on
side so he offered them a choice which
was either that they sign contracts with
the ministry of defense or that they go
home or that they go off in Exile to
Belarus he said that he would offer
um keep his promises on that front there
was no mention in that speech of yevgeni
prigojin directly or what his fate is we
understand that he might be now in Minsk
in Belarus but it's not entirely clear
and he didn't give any hints in that
video message that he delivered a little
earlier either but we're going to be
hearing from Alexander lukashenko the
Bella Russian leader at some point
tomorrow he was actually meant to be
scheduled to be talking around about the
same time as President Putin but I think
he may have been bigfooted there but I
think you know in that speech we heard
Vladimir Putin trying to tell the
Russian people that this whole threat to
their existence had been fended off by
their consolidation and solidarity as a
society well I would imagine that
actually the majority of people here in
Russia didn't really know about what was
happening until it was all over although
they probably do now because it's been
widely circulated on all the bulletins
and he may convince people that he has
this all under control but I think the
key question is whether he has the
backing and support of his Elites he's
currently meeting with his security
Chiefs right now Sergey shoigu is there
looking pretty tired and I don't think
he'll be getting rid of him anytime soon
but um you know what are those people
close to Vladimir Putin thinking now
that is the key question
Diana in Moscow and Dominic Inky thank
you
the inquest into the death of Nicola
bully saw video filmed by the divers who
searched for her today her pathologist
told Preston Coroner's court that she
had drowned after falling into the river
which may have been caused by taking
just one or two breaths of the freezing
cold water in the river wire modern
brunch reports
when Nicola bully disappeared in January
there was a three-week police search and
huge public concern but an inquest heard
she had drowned long before anyone
realized she was missing
it's believed she entered the water near
this bench a pathologist said she hadn't
been drinking and no one else was
involved the water was cold four degrees
and flowing faster than walking pace a
dangerous place to fall in said a police
diver in a video played to the coroner
those rocks
pretty much vertically straight down in
the water to around four meters of depth
there are some
trees overhang into the water
but it's fairly clear at the point of
entry
on both sides there's nothing that could
have stopped to
two witnesses said they saw Nicola
dropping her daughters off at school
before she headed to the river to walk
her dog an hour or so later both said
they heard a short scream from that
direction
nurse Helen O'Neill said it was unusual
at that time of day but it wasn't an
alarming scream in my head I had two
females walking along by the river and
one jumped out on the other I didn't
think anything of it until later on
Veronica Clayson said I was at the
tennis club and about to get into my car
when I heard a scream my immediate
thought was someone was having a laugh
in the graveyard it was a scream of
surprise
other Witnesses described how Nicola's
dog Willow was found near the river her
harness lying in the grass
Nicholas mobile phone was on the bench
when a woman called Nicola's partner
Paul he told her she's struggling
with a fall and the shock of cold water
said another witness Nicola would have
lost Consciousness within 50 seconds
maybe sooner
while police were still searching for
her they had revealed she'd had alcohol
problems brought on by her struggles
with the menopause
Nicola's body was recovered from the
river a mile and a half Downstream 23
days after she vanished
the inquest is being held over two days
with extra security the public seats
were full reflecting the huge interest
when Nicola disappeared on day two
nichola's partner Paul Ansel is expected
to give evidence
Martin brunt Sky News Preston
a man who may have led one of the most
notorious racist killings in British
history avoided Justice for nearly three
decades police admitted today the mother
of Stephen Lawrence said she was
infuriated that Matthew white who died
two years ago had not faced any charges
because of failings by the police Skies
Emma birchley reports
Gary Dobson and David Norris the only
two men eventually convicted of the
murder of Stephen Lawrence as he waited
for a bus in southeast London 30 years
ago
five men were named as suspects in the
unprovoked racist attack but there was
always talk of a sixth a fair-haired man
now it's been confirmed that that man
was Matthew White
but it's also emerged that police
failings meant it took 20 years to talk
to a relative of white who'd reported
his presence at the scene I'm shocked
I'm angry but if I'm Frank I'm not
surprised I'm in this family
the Lawrence family have had to go
through years and years of discovering
yet further failings from the Police
Service deep institutional racially
driven failings white was arrested twice
but never charged there was not believed
to be enough evidence he died in 2021
for Stephen's mother Doreen Lawrence
it's prompted fresh Fury that no
officers been punished for their role in
an investigation deemed to be hampered
by racism and alleged corruption
in a statement she said what is
infuriating about this latest Revelation
is that the man who is said to have led
the murderous attack on my son has
evaded Justice because of police
failures and yet not a single police
officer has faced or will ever Face
action
it's prompted yet another apology from
the Metropolitan Police acknowledging
too many mistakes with a lasting impact
were made a decision is yet to be taken
as to whether criminal charges will be
brought against four former officers for
their actions Emma birchley Sky News
the Prime Minister admitted there is
work to do in fixing the NHS after a
major study revealed that it
underperformed compared to other Health
Care Systems Rishi sunak also hinted
that he may ignore the independent pay
review bodies for public sector workers
if they recommend pay Rises which don't
reflect the economic context namely
inflation our political correspondent
Rob Powell has this report
we're rolling this out announcing a new
screening program for lung cancer the
Prime Minister out in Nottingham today
but still locked in a standoff with some
health unions Rishi sunak also hinted he
may overrule pay recommendations for
junior doctors if he deems them too high
people need to recognize the economic
context we're in and I'm going to make
the decisions that are the right ones
for the country that's not always easy
people may not like that but those are
the right things for everybody that we
get a grip of inflation and that means
the government not excessively borrowing
too much money and being responsible
with public sector pay settlement
also out on the wards labor adopting an
altogether blunder tone they're
definitely the worst hospital I've ever
been in the shadow Health secretary
attacking the government for a lack of
investment but less clear on the vexed
issue of pay I want to see the
independent pay review body process back
up and running with the full confidence
of everyone involved the real risk to
the NHS Now isn't just that staff walk
out for another five days of strike
action but they walk out of the NHS
altogether from strikes and Staffing to
hospital spending the NHS and the
government are facing challenges in the
short term and the long in the months
ahead further walkouts by doctors May
frustrate the prime minister's promise
to curb waiting lists but there's also
the risk of pay and conditions causing
more health workers to leave a worrying
Prospect for a service already short on
staff
analysis by the charity the king's fund
has found the UK has three practicing
doctors per 1000 people while Germany
and Denmark both have around four and a
half on nurses the UK figure is also low
at 8.5 per 1000 people compared to 12 in
Germany and 10 in Denmark
the report's author says this alongside
a lack of capital investment means the
UK is lagging behind on treatable health
conditions It's a combination of not
enough funding and poor planning the
budget for the NHS has been increasing
but by nowhere near enough if you wanted
this rapid growth of doctors and nurses
but the second thing is how we've
organized workforce planning in this
country simply hasn't been good enough
it was split along lots of different
National bodies no one was really
accountable Rishi sunak will try to
address this when he unveils a long-term
Workforce plan later this week
that won't help with many immediate NHS
issues though political problems focused
onto a Health Service already under
pressure
Sky News in Westminster
Princess Diana was well known for her
work with the homeless charity center
point today her son and heir to the
throne said he wanted to end
homelessness in five years it's a noble
cause for Prince William to take on
although it does also touch on the
province of Politics as our Royal
correspondent Laura bundock reports
six locations in two days as their
prince of Wales launches his life's
ambition a plan to end homelessness I
first visited homeless shelter when I
was 11 with my mother
the visits we made together left a deep
and Lasting Impression over the next
five years we have a unique opportunity
to develop Innovative new Solutions and
scale their tangible impact
this will inspire belief throughout the
UK and beyond that homelessness can be
ended for good
Newport in South Wales is one of the six
areas targeted by the project
stuck in a cycle of temporary housing
Wayne's been homeless here for over a
decade nearly eight years clean and but
I'm still struggling with a homelessness
regarding to get the flat so basically
I'm in a pod it's a like a shipping
container I'm just waiting on the
council name to basically move me
forward to get my own property basically
and that's what I'm at important
hopefully get a full-time job
all Wayne wants is a home but it's years
away and after so long waiting he
doesn't think homelessness will ever end
look how long it's been trying to get a
bit of homelessness no no offense I
don't think we'll ever get rid of the
homelessness but I wish we could but
it's not going to happen
with well-known faces the prince's
project will collaborate and convene to
find local solutions to end homelessness
a bold pledge say some given his
position of enormous privilege
Prince William is a huge landowner he
has multiple homes is he really the
right person to be standing there and
saying I can solve homelessness
who's the right person to solve and end
homelessness we've all got to do it he's
put his hand up and he said look I'm
committing to to play my part you could
you could make a real gesture imagine
giving over a house giving over a palace
that really wouldn't make a dent into
the situation we need structural
systemic change
it is a political issue for a prince who
sits above politics but he says it's not
about policy just action and positive
change Laura bundock Sky News Newport
one of Britain's most senior medical
officials has told the covert inquiry
that Public Health Resources across the
country were probably not good enough to
cope with the pandemic Professor Dame
Jenny Harris the chief executive of the
UK Health Security Agency admitted that
services in some areas were
under-resourced
it is fair to say and I'm pretty
confident it's evidence that some of the
health protection skills were denuded
from particularly from the smaller local
authorities where you perhaps have one
director of Public Health one consultant
and one other really quite small
the authorities in Myanmar have set fire
to 350 million pounds worth of drugs to
Mark international anti-drug trafficking
day the country is a major producer and
exporter of methamphetamine and the
world's second largest opium and heroin
producer after Afghanistan
former Scotland Football manager Craig
Brown has died at the age of 82 after a
short illness Craig Brown was the last
manager to lead Scotland to a World Cup
final taking charge of the team in
France in 1998. he was Scotland manager
for 70 games making him the country's
longest serving manager
foreign
years since Andy Murray last won
Wimbledon and even his most Ardent fans
might accept that would be a tall order
now Britain's most successful modern
player though isn't yet planning on
hanging up his racket he's told Sky News
he was speaking to my colleague Jackie
beltrell
heading into a 15th Wimbledon and his
third with a metal hip Andy Murray is
confident he can still challenge the
world's best but realistically could
this be the 36 year old's last outing at
the Championships I hope not
um but you never know if I was to have
another big injury or something happened
with the
you know the metal hit that would that
would be me finished you know I want to
finish on my own terms I want to finish
on the court whilst I still feel I can
do my self-justice and I'm playing at a
really high level and
um you know I definitely feel I can do
that for a couple more years well Andy
Murray has been grinding out the wins on
the lower tier Challenger circuit his
great childhood rival Novak Djokovic has
just won a record-breaking 23rd Grand
Slam title at the French Open and we'll
go for a record equaling eighth Title
Here at Wimbledon so does that make
Novak the greatest of all time there's
arguments there for him to be the the
greatest of all time those three guys on
their surfaces
um you know that's Rafa on the clay I
mean I don't think anyone can doubt he's
the best clay Court player of all time
for me Novak because clearly the best
hardcore player of all time and then
grass is kind of still to be still to be
decided between probably him and him and
Roger and
um but yeah what all those guys have
achieved is is amazing
um you know if you just go on Grand Slam
titles then you know you would have to
have to give that to Novak but for me
it's just slightly more nuanced the
Russians and the Russians returned to
Wimbledon for the first time in two
years and while Murray doesn't have a
problem facing players from those
countries it's caused Great upheaval
within the sport I mean I have competed
against players from those countries and
I you know I wouldn't say that as has
affected me I mean you know I've the
utmost sympathy for all of the Ukrainian
players that are playing and are put in
that that situation and also the
tournaments are you know they're also in
a really they've been put in a really
difficult situation Murray won't be
seated at Wimbledon his ranking isn't
high enough but the two-time champion
remains a huge draw around here Jackie
Bell trout Sky News Wimbledon
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including the story from the Daily Star
giving advice to the Wagner leader you
have any precaution on his personal
safety after appearing to challenge
President Putin best stay away they say
from open Windows well tonight we're
joined by the political editor of the
Guardian for the career and the
political editor of the sun Harry Cole
that in just a moment
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
well this is Guy news in just a moment
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages first though a
reminder of our top stories this evening
Vladimir Putin has summoned his security
officials to discuss an attempted
Rebellion by the Wagner group of
mercenaries and insisted that Russia is
United behind him
the question to Nicola Bully's death
hears that she drowned and there was no
alcohol in her blood when she fell into
the river wire
and the fury of the mother of Stephen
Lawrence that a sixth suspect may have
evaded Justice for her son's murder
[Music]
hello there you are watching The Press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what is
making the headlines with the political
editor of the guardian papakura and the
political editor of the son Harry Cole
welcome to both of you so let's take a
look at the front pages Then Shall We
The Guardian leads on that statement
from Vladimir Putin earlier where he
claimed that his enemies wanted Russia
to choke in bloody civil Strife the head
of the Wagner militia has denied trying
to overthrow the Russian government
that's on the front of the financial
times same story there is some safety
advice for Afghani pregosian on the
front page of the star best stay away
from open windows
in other news a call for Bank branches
to retain their presence on the High
Street makes the top story for the
express the Metro leading on the inquest
into the death of Nicola bully which
heard that she drowned after falling
into a river
a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
we're joined then by Pippa career and
Harry Cole and Pippa we've heard haven't
we from both pragossian and Putin today
um you know possibly different stories
but you know can Putin you know regain
his hard man image do you think after
the extraordinary events of this weekend
I think it's going to be very hard for
him I mean what has happened in Russia
um we're still trying to you know
exactly what's happened we're still
trying to find out and um isn't entirely
clear although we have had a bit more
information that you say Anna
um in the form of an 11-minute telegram
address from pagosian uh earlier on and
then of course Vladimir Putin's really
quite angry television statement
um to the Russian people and what seems
to have happened and it's obviously
we're you know analysts are much more
expert than Harry or I are pouring over
all of this but what seems to have
happened is that
um a fairly sort of um I wouldn't quite
say standard but but a dispute between
two senior figures in um in the the
Russian the Moscow regime
um the the defense minister and
obviously the head of Wagner
um have uh their their conflict which
um I think in in other times might have
been resolved with a judge from Putin on
which side he fell down he fell on um
and obviously the dispute was based
around Wagner and pragosian's feeling
that the defense minister and the
defense Ministry Russian army hadn't
hadn't prosecuted the invasion of
Ukraine in the way that it should have
done
um and uh that didn't happen Putin
didn't come down with a judgment and so
uh Wagner marched on Moscow with these
extraordinary uh images and
extraordinary circumstances that we saw
over the weekend which have I think
irrevocably rocked Putin's position and
given the ongoing uncertainty made it
very difficult
um for the rest of us let alone you know
those in those in Russia to see exactly
how this is going to play out and how
this power play is going to is going to
culminate
yes and the financial times picking up
on the pregosian statement this evening
rather than the Putin one
um with the denial that he tried to oust
Putin uh in his 11 minute voice
recording he said his goal was to
protest against a recent decision to
disband Wagner and to demonstrate the
weakness of Russia's domestic defenses
we didn't have the goal of toppling the
existing regime from Putin's point of
view though his statement is video
statement tonight said I emphasized from
the very beginning of the events all the
necessary decisions were immediately
taken to neutralize the threat that had
Arisen to protect the Constitutional
order the life and security of our
citizens which seemed so strange when
the Wagner group got so far Harry what
you know what's your thoughts of of what
happened over the weekend and what were
to make of it
the first hour we as people said you
know carry out this with you know most
western intelligence agencies are still
grappling with what's exactly happened
um at the weekend we don't know this is
obviously a very fluid situation and a
live moving situation still all this
talk of a deal done um you know
obviously because was able to flee but
in his statements tonight Putin appears
to have revoked any suggestion that you
know he's off the hook for this
um it took um Trotsky 14 years of
looking over his shoulder before the ice
pick finally came all the way in Mexico
um Bella Russia is not that far from uh
from from Moscow so I'm not Imagining
the iron former now bargain boss is
sleeping too easily at the moment uh and
uh having watched that statement from
Putin that's not a man that looks like
he's gonna back down one thing I would
say is though do not underestimate the
that Putin it's clear that the the that
vagina column as it was advancing up
towards the capital was not being joined
in this in in the way that it was it
needed to be if this was going to be a
successful purchase for all this idea
that now it wasn't that it wasn't a coup
that's not what the guy was saying at
the time he was saying in fact the exact
opposite he made some pretty bellicose
direct threats to the regime to very
senior figures in it and what's clear is
that it inspires it's his FSB the gru
whoever did not join with uh in fact the
Russian military hate that though
because they've embarrassed them along
the way on many occasions over the last
few years so they were kind of caught
with their trousers down halfway to the
capital and decided to run away so
um I would um I wouldn't be sleeping too
easy if I was exiled in Bella Russia
tonight well absolutely that's the front
page of the star isn't it uh best stay
away from open Windows
um you know there is a ruthlessness
certainty uh that President Putin has
shown anybody who he uh deems to have
committed treason against the nation you
know deal or no deal we'll see what
happens
um you know where is precaution now is
he in mince because there are some
reports what happens to his you know his
Wagner foot soldiers will they take up
the offer of merging with the uh with
the Russian Ministry of defense will
they go home to their families will they
go to Belarus
um you know have they lost the the best
fighting force that Russia is so far you
know presented itself with Pippa
well percussion in his uh remarks
earlier seemed to suggest that his
troops would not sign contracts uh with
the Russian Ministry of Defense now as
far as I can make out he is he remains
popular with the Wagner troops and um
and as it has a sort of a strong
personal following so without him on the
scene or without his Blessing it's
unlikely that that substantial numbers
of Wagner troops will will sign up to
the ministry of Defense not least
because
um it's run by Sergey shoigu who who of
course was is the individual who um who
most has most upset
um pagosjin and the and the Wagner group
for his handling of the Ukraine conflict
so um he seemed to be suggesting
precaution this is that um the vaginal
troops might actually come to Belarus
with him and put in also similarly in
his address suggested that that might be
an option for to them there's some
suggestion that lukashenko the president
Alexander the president of Belarus might
allow the vagina group to train
um on on their territory that obviously
then opens up the prospect of
um the conflict moving into Ukraine from
the north of Ukraine directly from
Belarus which is obviously going to be
something on the ground in Ukraine which
zelenski and his
um his generals will be will be watching
very closely
um it is all just shredded in a great
deal of uncertainty but you know as as
we've seen as Harry says anybody that
that sort of challenges Putin directly
even those including who were once seen
as as you know a real sort of loyal
supporter a better watch I I mean we saw
last September a prominent Russian oil
um oligarch ending up falling out
falling out of the sixth floor of a a
Russian a Russian Hospital Moscow
hospital and he was just the latest in
the series of uh senior Russian
individuals who have in some way or
other angered or stood up to the Putin
regime reaching a similar fate so you
know that's the front page of the star
so as we've already said I don't think
precaution is going to be sleeping very
well in his bed tonight in Minsk or
wherever else he actually is
picking up on you know what what
Russia's enemies wanted uh the
organizers of the Rebellion uh having
betrayed their country their people
betrayed those who were drawn into the
crime pushed them pushed them to death
Under Fire to shoot at their own he
called it fracticide that the enemies of
Russia wanted uh in Kiev the neonats is
in Kiev and their Western patrons and
all sorts of national traitors I mean
the words of Putin uh this evening
um but indeed yes I mean Ukraine would
have you know rubbed its hands with Glee
at this at this activity it's all these
extra and incidental elements that have
made the war so extraordinary in recent
months the kakovka dam
um for one
um the raids into Belgard by the free
Russia troops and now this whatever it
was this Rebellion Harry
um it didn't go on low enough really for
for Ukraine to feel the benefit on the
front line of of this action yeah I
think one thing that was quite clear was
that the troops stationed on the front
were not diverted back to the motherland
to try and fight this it was as you say
over too quickly but I mean as a loss of
face reputation this cannot be played
down I think the West has sort of agreed
this joint line that it shows real
cracks but have stopped short of saying
it's going to be it's going to be fatal
um if anything that could actually have
the opposite effect of forcing an
already fairly ruthless uh leader
um to crack down even further on his
country I have to say if you're a
Russian citizen who hasn't got watching
television over the last few months and
years has been told everything's going
brilliantly
um so then suddenly see your your leader
on televisions without quite blood
curdling series of statements the one on
Saturday morning and the one tonight
um you know it's very hard to contain
the idea that everything's going
tickety-boo when you have to go on
television and say actually you know
blood was being spilled six planes were
being shot down there was fracture side
going on in the country so I I wonder
how you know as a sort of PR uh moment
for the Putin regime whether that's
going to be the real damage that people
aren't necessarily going to believe a
single word he's saying anymore and uh
just as I spoke in fact I see a um a
drop on the Reuters news agency uh
zielinski saying we are making advances
in all sectors it is a happy day
um I don't know any more context than
that but uh but we'll certainly see um
we know that he visited uh the front
line as well himself uh today so um you
know this this story continues obviously
let's move on though if we can to the
Stephen Lawrence case
um you know clearly of great distress
once again to to Steven's family Pippa
the idea that yet again Justice was not
served in this case
yeah it's very sad this story isn't it I
mean I just your heart just breaks for
um for Neville and Dorian Lawrence
Stevens parents who after all these
years 30 years are still having to go
through the turmoil of feeling that
Justice hasn't been done for their son
and that
um they can't even be at peace
um the the
um the this was an official
investigation
um uh has concluded the Scotland Yard
had information that could and should
have been handed into to the inquiry
into Lawrence's murder of a field to
disclose it
um and you know the met this obviously
comes after The Met
um the sixth suspect in his killing was
identified
um and Stephen Lawrence's father and
Dwayne Brooks who had obviously was
their
um uh in that street in Nelson when he
was attacked and murdered had called for
the Met to reopen the investigation so
this was um an individual called Matthew
white he he died in 2021
um and the police had twice looked into
him
um but seemed to slip through their
fingers
um and it's obviously once again raises
huge questions about
um the original met inquiry
um it concerns also about what the Met
told the MacPherson inquiry which was
the the inquiry that obviously took
place
um in the in the uh the years following
the the Lawrence case and concluded that
the Met was institutionally racist and
actually
um led to some really quite profound
changes in in British policing in
general not just in the mid
um as a result of the McPherson report
but there's questions that even met
maybe hadn't been completely straight
with what they knew and didn't know when
it came to
um dealing with McPherson so you know I
just I just feel really sad about it for
the family's perspective that this is
this is not yet been laid to rest um
that there are obviously other
individuals who were
who were involved in this that they
haven't yet been brought to Justice
um and still many many unanswered
questions for the for the Lawrence
Family and many questions that they met
itself still has to answer on this as
well indeed so lots more still to come
the next part of our program stay there
both of you if you can man including the
six figure sum for every migrant sent to
Rwanda more on that after the break
[Music]
well he's got a convening power that
very few other people have a convening
superpower really isn't it to bring
people together to solve what is still
not really recognized as one of the
biggest challenges we face as a country
and I think he's shining a light on the
size of the problem he's shining a light
on the partnership needed to end
homelessness and he's also showing
leadership which I think is really
important because
um actually you know we really do need
action on this
um and that leadership from the prince I
think will make a really big difference
what we've found at shelter in our work
at local level is you know the prince is
absolutely right actually it does take
all agencies in a local area to come
together to solve this problem but it
does also take some government action
and we can't ignore that it's not his
role to push for that that's our role to
push for that but it is really important
that all political parties understand
um this needs to be a big issue in the
run-up to the election and all the
parties need to understand but it takes
it's going to take some serious will
from political wills and government um
so in Finland uh there are two main I
guess things
um first of all they put resources
around the person
they don't expect people to go from door
to door to door to door retelling their
story hundreds of times in order to get
a little bit of help from each agency
they're much better coordinated at local
level and I think that's something the
prince can do but there's another thing
in Finland too which is that they do
have social housing they have homes to
put people in and that's a significant
difference between Finland and the UK so
apparently the prince is committed to
building social homes on his estate and
I guess that's what I mean by leadership
that would be absolutely fantastic to
prove that social homes is a what the
country needs be achievable and see that
people in local communities want this
people don't want their communities
hollowed out because young people can't
afford to live there anymore you know
communities need decent high quality
social homes and that I hope if he
demonstrates that that will be hugely
powerful
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
with me once again the political editor
of the Guardian paper career and the
political editor of the sun Harry Cole
welcome back to both of you let's take a
look shall we pepper at the guardian the
costing for Rwanda and the contrast with
what would happen if refugees and Asylum
Seekers were held here what are the
figures
yeah so this is a big this is a as a big
reveal if you like the government have
been under pressure for some time to
publish
um their impact assessment of their
illegal migration Bill and uh they did
so today and it suggests that the cost
of sending a single person seeking
Asylum drewanda could be almost 170
000 pounds
um uh zuella bravaman points out that
um the government could save uh as far
as she's concerned a hundred thousand
pounds so every person deterred from
coming here but uh the impact assessment
also points out that there's little to
no evidence that policy changes such as
just deter people from leaving the homes
and coming to coming to the UK or indeed
elsewhere this is not just a UK
phenomenon obviously
um so um the conclusion seems to be that
it would cost us an awful lot of money
um to send people to Rwanda obviously
the government's already spent I think
it's about 140 million pounds um on this
Arrangement under Boris Johnson and no
doubt they'll be further humans if the
scheme gets up and running but it's
going to be pivotal week because not
only have you had this impact assessment
but we're expecting the court of appeal
decision on Thursday on whether the
legislation is legal or not uh sending
over women and children as well to
Amanda and also on uh I think that's on
Thursday and then on Wednesday the uh
the bill is back in the House of Lords
where of course it has run into quite a
lot of challenges already and it's
expected
um potentially to run into more and do
they know Harry if it'll work
um certainly the quote is that the
official assessment warns the deterrent
effect claimed by ministers is highly
uncertain
yeah I mean that's the point is this
hasn't been tried before this is a new
and novel approach as the as the policy
has been pretty clear to State it hasn't
been allowed to you know you can't you
can't cry this doesn't work when you've
spent every single fiber of your time
and being trying to block it from being
tried so it is a bit of a confused sort
of attack tonight from the from The
Usual Suspects and critics of this
policy that oh it it says it doesn't
work no it hasn't been tried so there's
a there's a bit of a a difference there
look it is going to be expensive this
isn't meant to be a cost efficient way
of of holding people it's meant to act
as a deterrent so it basically says if
you drive down the the the the rate of
people arriving in this country
illegally by 37 then it becomes cost
neutral because obviously the cost of
not doing anything means that the seven
billion pound figure that we use for
housing Asylum Seekers at the moment
will rise to 11 billion pounds a year so
it's to me it's a it's a throw of the
dice for the government they've never
really really said it's anything other
than that
um but the what is the alternative do we
just do nothing throw open our borders
watch things go up we're not going to
get a returns agreement with with France
they've got their own immigration
problems everyone sort of harks back to
this great Dublin Accord that we had as
members of the EU it didn't work at the
time it was rubbish there was a couple a
couple of hundred people sent back to
various countries a year on it so
something fundamentally has to change
and the government are basically saying
well look if it's not this then then
what and I suspect what will happen is
you know any incoming government is
going to be greeted with the same
problems after the next election so you
know labor saying they're going to throw
a couple hundred million quid to the NCA
to put you know do extra gang policing
if they come into power as it looks like
they're going to next year they're going
to find that's not going to cut it
either so something has to give and um I
suspect I mean our readers are quite
interested in this policy they're not as
critical about it as as as some people
are and actually public support for this
policy despite knowing it's expensive
remains fairly strong for uh for uh for
a tactic in fact I see um you're talking
about next year uh page two of the sun
suggests that most Tory members think
Zakir starmer is going to win the next
general election a survey uh by the
con-home website for Grassroots activist
fam 30 were resigned to a labor majority
29 to a labor-led coalition that's 60 of
Tory uh supporters thinking that they
are effectively toast or their party is
um and uh thought uh Pippa uh the
photographs which are on many a front
page and inside two of
um The Chain Reaction or the chain mail
of the fleabag star Phoebe Waller Bridge
a chain reaction is how this paper
describes it for the um
Premiere tonight with the co-star of
Harrison Ford aged 80 who plays the
adventurer in this film
yes Indiana Indiana Jones is back she
looks amazing doesn't she um I mean I'm
delighted because I'm a massive Indiana
Jones fan although I have to say I
watched the most regularly when I was it
was my children's age so uh whether um
whether Indiana Jones whether Harrison
Ford in his 80s can crack it if he can
he can crack the whip and and sort of
you know leap leap over
um obstacles and and you know speed off
in cars and do whatever stunts uh he did
previously
um we'll have to we'll have to see and
then my children are excited about
seeing it but um but yeah he's not quite
the sort of uh live and uh and uh uh
energetic hero that uh that he was uh as
a younger man but um I think the the
Allure of Harrison Ford and Indiana
Jones anymore anyway will meet me
amongst others tune in
um to watch it okay I'm sure we all will
Pippa Harry thank you both very much
Denise see you next time thank you uh
season for the 11th the weather's now
memories wherever you go
you go the weather sponsored by Qatar
Airways so cooler this week quite
unsettled some parts look like staying
mainly dry quite a warm start tomorrow
sunny spells for much of a Southern and
Eastern Britain most other places
overcast with outbreaks of rain
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways